so let me just explain to explain to the
viewers here why this isn't just some
like psychological geek conversation
this is actually really relevant to a
lot of the things that we'll be talking
about and that your audience is about
because one of the most contested ideas
in the social sciences is the idea of
innate Ness and the idea is well if
something is innate then it can't it
can't vary across societies and if it
varies across societies then it's not an
eight and if gender varies if
masculinity or femininity vary across
societies it it's not an eight it's
socially constructed but that's the
wrong understanding of an anus the
definition that I use comes from Gary
Marcus was actually a neuroscientist
here at NYU he says innate doesn't mean
hardwired is almost nothing interesting
that's hardwired innate means
structured in advance of experience but
then experience can still revise it and
boy does that work for gender for almost
everything for yeah that's right almost
everything that we're not a blank slate
about anything and something I used to
tell my students at UVA I taught at UVA
for 16 years is you know everything's a
social construction masculinity
femininity cancer the Sun death
everything there's a social construction
for you won't find a society that
doesn't have thoughts about these things
but the fact that societies have social
constructions tells us nothing about
whether there's not also an underlying
biological reality and in almost all
cases there is well otherwise we
wouldn't be able to communicate which is
one of evil Wilsons comments right when
I mean Wilson is the entomologist to
study dance at Harvard and also wrote a
number of books about sociobiology that
got him in trouble with the radical
leftists and he said even if we could
communicate with ants there would be
nothing to say to each other because
their fundamental mode of being in the
world is based on motivations and
interests that are so different from
ours that there wouldn't be any
structure for communication and you can
kind of tell that with regards to the
animals that we make friends with right
we're much more likely to make friends
with animals who has who have a
fundamental biological and social nature
that's very close to ours like dogs
because we can basically speak their
language even though nor completely a
mammal language of love and you know I
miss you and I want to play with you
yeah that's
yeah exactly and that's bonding yeah